the Mediterranean Sea reamed by 46,000
kilometers of coast has been one of the
world's greatest trade routes for
thousands of years its seabed still
holds treasures of the Greek Roman and
Egyptian empires that once ruled from
the shores
m4a from ancient shipwrecks are
scattered along the windswept coast of
western Turkey near tectus
about 80 kilometers northwest of Sicily
the waters hold a bank of eight
shipwrecks some dating back to the Roman
Empire
archeologists are discovering relics
including intact glass cups polished to
a cloudy transparency by the sea
as a young man Jacques Cousteau fell in
love with the Mediterranean Sea diving
among the coral reefs finding creatures
like the picky nudibranch that has a
taste for only one species of sponge the
fireworm whose white hairs can deliver a
painful burn and the green algae that
turns silver that dies the creatures
fascinated him from the artfully
camouflaged score Pina rock fish to sea
urchins with their voracious appetite
for algae
these waters led Cousteau to develop the
Aqualung which he said made it possible
to hang attached to nothing a dream I
often had visions of flying by extending
my arms as wings now I flew without
wings
another icon of the Mediterranean Sea is
likely the fastest fish in the ocean the
bluefin tuna called the cheetah of the
sea
no human device can exceed the tunas
amazing propulsion efficiency fueled by
a diet of small fish but even a racing
bluefin cannot escape the hooks nets the
commercial fishing aimed at satisfying a
global luxury working for tuna
Cerre baked broiled and wrong the sushi
and sashimi
a single two hundred kilogram tuna may
be shipped to Tokyo and sold for more
than 100 thousand US dollars the tunas
are not alone among the seas endangered
species the rarest and most endangered
are the monk seals which have been
prized for their meat and fur and also
have been killed off by fishermen to
eliminate them as competitors for fish
today they're fewer than 500
mediterranean monk seals and although
they're officially protected they may
not survive more than 1/2 billion tons
of sewage a year pour into the
Mediterranean Sea and the monk seals
homes have been displaced by human
structures many died tangled in fishing
gear others are slaughtered illegally as
more people come to know about the ocean
and take action to care for it there's
hope that the Mediterranean will be more
than just a sea of Legends
you